- It's Friday of we love LA
week and an honor of our season
three premiere.
We've been asking some LA icons
to share their LA top three.
(upbeat music)
These aren't any old places
you'd find in a travel guide for
a quick search on the internet.
Each top three list is a very
personal curated compilation
of the off the beaten path
spots. Not many know about.
Today, we've got the voice of
LA and host of the nationalist
syndicated big boy's neighborhood,
which you can hear on Real 92.3 FM and LA.
It's legendary radio disc jockey. Big boy.
Get on down here.
(audience claps)
Hello.
Yes.
- How are you?
Congratulations.
I heard that you just got
your star on the walk of fame,
right?
- Yes
(inaudible)
- I deserved it
after 27 Years of radio.
27 years of radio.
I'm telling you I got
to start in Hollywood.
I never thought that I would
get a star in Hollywood.
- It's amazing.
I was a kid, you know, I
grew up in Los Angeles.
I would go to Hollywood.
And at one point, you know,
we were homeless in our lives.
I would walk from Hollywood
because I didn't have bus fare.
So I would literally walk.
And you would read the
stars as you're walking now.
- And you're one of them now.
- Now, I'm that guy.
(audience claps)
- That's awesome
Kelly.
I go by my star all the time
and I was just standing there
hoping somebody polish it,
hoping somebody would recognize me.
- Oh, my star.
- Just happen to be right here.
(audience laughs)
- But wait, you love this
city. So I wanted to ask,
could you give us,
cause I don't know this city
as well as everybody else I've
lived in Texas and Tennessee, mostly.
So could you give us your
top three or you know,
places to see live music.
- Live music. There are a great spots.
One spot I would say is, the
Conga room and the Conga room
is good. It's not as big,
but they have live great
music there. Latin fusion.
They have great Latin nights.
- Where is this at?
- This is downtown. This is downtown
right near the Staples Center.
- Okay.
- Right there at the
walk. If you get a chance,
you should go there and their
Latin nights are unbelievable.
- What's number two?
- Number two for me, is the Greek theater.
- Oh, I love the Greek.
- Of course.
And the Greek theater is one
of those places where we have
a lot of spots out here.
That's kind of so-called
under the stars, but the
Greek is just this feeling.
It's an ambiance. It's the way
that the music sounds there.
And for me personally,
that's where I saw one
of my first concerts.
It was George Benson in 19.
(cough)
(audience laughs)
- It was a good time.
- I went there, but I
went with my brother.
My brother would love music.
and he took me to this show.
And once I got into radio,
I was in a position where I
could take him to the Greek
theater, take them
backstage, meet some people.
That was another place that
we had to take the bus to
and walk all the way up
the hill from Vermont.
So, to actually drive
him and take him there,
amazing.
- Oh my gosh, I love that.
I'm actually about to
see John Legend there.
(audience claps)
(inaudible)
- And your number one
place to see live music.
- Number one place.
There's a little spot downtown Los Angeles
as well, it's called the Belasco.
- Belasco?
- Belasco. B-E-L-A-S-C-O.
- Okay.
- And it's a spot where
it was an old theater.
They kind of went in and
refurbished and redone the spot,
but you could see up and
coming great talent there.
People that usually stopped
through Los Angeles,
they'll perform there as well
to get a little more intimate
with their crowds.
- I love that.
- A beautiful place downtown Los Angeles.
- I love that you mentioned
like intimate places.
Cause that's the coolest
thing ever. I think.
- I throw some birthday
parties there too, you know?
- Oh okay.
- So I'm in a position where
a lot of people don't show
it to my birthday parties.
So I got to go a little more empty.
(audience laughter)
- Well, thank you so much, Big Boy.
Thank you for joining us.
It was an honor to have you
here, and congrats on the star.
- I'll take that. Thank you guys.
- Give it up for Big Boy, everybody.
(audience claps)